how's it gone breath my name is purify
and welcome back to some more missile
well it's yeah hi hi guy what's up oh
yeah thanks goodness yes i Fidelia just
in time now stared now the chatroom a
long time
what since nobody's around we're free to
look in mr. Soto's desk oh come on it's
no time for that
look at what's happening to the skull
look tapped our pact will alert to miss
Isola who dares who isn't who dared to
send love letters to my mr. shota let's
find out is this like the overly
attached girlfriend let's find a way by
what they wrote
Ayaka that really doesn't matter right
now so let's get the [ __ ] out of here no
way I can see everything and I haven't
even looked in the bottom drawer you can
pass the opportunity but I done diddly
more fine what do I care
[ __ ] alright nothing out of the
ordinary nothing at it that's a watch I
save on the watches or did I click see
by accident I think I couldn't see by
actor locket II do like I do not gonna
do lock it and - quad napple docketed a
coupe that's what I always Akal what are
we doing here it's not three that
[ __ ] note again that's for shun [ __ ]
leisurely filled with water
well don't kill me whoa I like this whoa
how do I use the bad baby bleep back
don't kill me like I can go so many
places where the [ __ ] am I supposed to
go what the [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] with me game what what but
that I'm sorry I'm sorry
what huh whoops okay I should have
figured that out
I should have shunted leash [ __ ]
[ __ ] free dude figure that out what oh
god damn it she exploded that's what you
get for holding in your fart bros
stained dress you'll explode from the
inside I can't don't buy adorn what that
a clue oh [ __ ] toilers fire extinguisher
pick it up no I like that you can save
the game at any time whoa what deaf [ __ ]
I'm going into [ __ ] there yeah haha man
it's me
I have to savor I need something to
drive it away what about this fire
extinguisher perfect now I can get that
Amos Barrett pitch please you can fire
extinguisher and evil but good night
Sudama how dare you do this to Tommy
take this monster but the [ __ ] did she
do I'm sorry I couldn't save you
it's that big bag though is that a poo
or is it that character that was like
because I kind of liked her I mean we
can't go in there
so what was the point of going it uh I
don't know I like this so far
maybe even more than that father uh just
[ __ ] aah
oh here we go again are you [ __ ]
serious
there we go pieces I'm gonna save her
don't trust it Kat say hello hello hello
well I went better than expected
we can't go that well we shall go of it
nothing out of the ordinary
well we can get something here maybe I
don't know let's take it take a nap I
don't see why I don't know you need that
nap - whoa what
that's [ __ ] creepy man don't take
naps brochacho oh [ __ ] May I'm never
taking a nap again nothing out of the
ordinary
what about Slenderman over here creepy
and stares right at you I don't like
this for ChaCha's nothing out of there
what no more [ __ ] naps I learned that
much off what that doesn't even comment
about it Oh fine how yes you know what
the [ __ ] what the hell - Delia yeah how
my heart don't help her this is
interesting because you're probably
gonna affect the ending a lot because
she bullied a Miss ow good I like her so
I'm gonna help her I'd like to help you
but you're always bullying in people huh
what what about it if you promise not to
bully weak people anymore now I'll be
willing to help you alright
Jade sure I want Dora
not help me out of here he's gonna come
back if you don't hurry
who oh hey ik he's here says mad father
no I don't want to be a test of yet if
I'm fun I'm done for it got a hide
somewhere where can I hide oh [ __ ]
gosh Fred you're a jerk the box
dad's death yes jaidev's pin strikes
again
fresh same - a fine hola
that's [ __ ] nature I held in my fart
again keep Khalid [ __ ] cheap Steph's
man does admittedly that'll be me help
ah nothing happened
why does it work with Eve no I don't
know what it out oneness a satsang no
stop
No what the [ __ ] is the carrot thing oh
I'm all red now looks like the monster
left here I'm covered in blood gotta
wash myself somewhere oops totally
forgot about saving Yosh you know did it
the [ __ ] is wrong with me what the hell
are the game saves automatically as well
the capsule contains something unknown
did I kill myself forget oh it's the
mushroom
hey my shen that's party oh I thought ya
can make mushroom
I mean carrot thing whatever the [ __ ]
that is
hey could you watch me don't pee on me
whoa what done padilha I was stunned by
the telephone hit the wall and gave a
final breath jamás deaf ever chased by a
carrot and the phone rings and then you
[ __ ] that reminds me of when Taylor
Swift was scared by Ln like [ __ ] Wow
oh maybe I'll die being Starla wanna zip
punch one of the switches coolest peeps
ranking bruenig old man Rick Nikki Verde
train you are April red may Y June as
their coolest Peeta
ebrill have like stupid [ __ ] like that
in your school luckily within am I
supposed to make this carrot mango
somewhere I don't get it
everyone is [ __ ] dies oh we can go
outside all right
this looks kind of [ __ ] up a temple
what the hell yo she knows grave oh they
have that means two more is gonna die
someone's grave oh [ __ ] oh snap eise no
nothing happens
what about you sacrifice the body or the
cows would never end
shut up bird's nest you can't tell me
what you do birds now what about this
well what I went down Diddley down-down
builders I don't even know what that is
oh I just smack that smack my balls are
I died well I became as a Bey I'm
beautiful get going well let's not do
that
hi this is classroom I'm gonna guess
something is in here
nah nothing oh [ __ ] well as I pussy-ass
shredder dama Wow ah that is let's calm
down he's just made for them oh he's odd
because I'm covered in blood why are
your bloody you always struck me as
tough but I always I guess you're really
a coward but what's that still I can't
believe sir Tommy's dead Oh Tommy it
ain't my fault I didn't do nothing wrong
it's all miss out damn it miss I was
gonna kill me help me Adelia you help me
then we'll save miss out together huh
don't be fooling it's myself myself ah
darling this happened why the hell do
you wanna I don't know what do you want
to save it Bruce would you rather stay
here forever because I don't care what
happened here late ask what why it up
alright I'll do I'll do whatever just
don't leave me alone
alright don't fall behind yeah okay
let's go
what oh what Oh Tama Thomas stay with me
AK oh good it's still breathing I'll
have to get him treated am i holding him
or something and why is that
evil voice so evil um okay so I think
their former pharmacies downstairs I'm
not sure breath I keep thinking I'm
seeing [ __ ] like Paulo [ __ ] Fitz what
are we doing to your character with I
there's two left to die um we're gonna
check over here
one character left to die
oh he's humping the wall now I can do
that too two can play that game
I'm just kidding I'm not gonna do that
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna die here this game
gives me the [ __ ] goosebumps Oh what
that so Misao jump from the roof is that
it I don't know I do not done diddly
[ __ ] like this I'm going back [ __ ]
goosebumps man oh the body's gone that's
fun psycho Felix I can do cats it night
bed pot I'm alright
run run run run run run I wonder if I
can make it what what what what
I did it I'm a [ __ ] genius what's up
what's up oh I got something I shouldn't
have done this
oh [ __ ] oh I wish your way the blood
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay let's go in
here I want that [ __ ]
I found a pot of Miss our hope you bros
enjoy this episode like leave a like if
you did subscribe come abruptly now see
your brothers and xs